[Music]
yeah I'm gonna tell you about the matrix
Chernoff bound for strongly Riley
distributions and as an example of what
we can do with that I'll then show how
to get spectral sparsa fires from a few
random spanning trees and this is a
joint work with za song you know please
ask questions say things are not clear I
hope this will seem like a very kind of
easy thing that we did but there are
some nice questions left over that might
maybe aren't so easy so yeah the
question starts with concentration of
scalar random variables if we have
independent X I which are real valued
and the some of them we called X is X
then close to its expectation with high
probability that's the question we're
used to things like Chernoff bounds or
central limit theorems and you know
Gaussian distribution that's
concentrated around its mean so
chernov's inequality is an example of a
set of conditions where we can make
these statements precise about how
concentrated at some of independent
random variables are so we have random
positive x i we have that the sum it's X
the expectation of the sum is mu each of
the random variables is always bounded
by R and then we get that the
probability that X deviates from its
expectation by more than epsilon mu is
that most two exponential of minus mu
epsilon squared by r2 plus Epsilon just
as an example we could plug in some
numbers it's not so important what they
are but if I take epsilon to be 1/2 and
R to be 1 and mu to be 10 log 1 over tau
I get a probability bound of tau so this
is sort of typical of how we want to do
this kind of thing now what if we have
independent random matrices so now we're
going to think about having a collection
of independent random X I which are D PI
D will also say symmetric and X is the
sum of these X I and we want to know is
X close to its expectation with high
probability
we can say that with things like matrix
Chernoff bound here I'll talk through a
version due to truck but there's
important earlier work by rural Sun and
Aceveda and winter in this setting we
have independent random X I which are
deep ID positive semi-definite matrices
X is the sum of these and we say that
the spectral norm of the expectation of
X is mu each of the X I is always
bounded and spectral norm by r and then
we get the probability that x minus its
expectation has spectral norm more than
epsilon is D where D is the dimension
times what we had in the scalar case so
it looks pretty much like we just did a
Union bound over each of the eigenvalues
to say that we were good in each
eigenvalue direction although
technically what happens is a bit more
complicated than that and as an example
we can plug in epsilon to be 1/2 R to be
1 mu to be 10 log T by tau and then
we'll get the probability bound here is
tau ok this is exciting to a computer
scientist because the only thing that
changed from the scalar case was a D
inside this log that sounds like
something I can afford in a lot of
algorithmic settings and that's one of
the reasons why these things are very
useful ok but what if the variables are
not independent let's go back to the
scalar setting so suppose we have X
which is a zero one valued random
variable and Y is equal to X all the
time
then X plus y is not any more
concentrated than just X right it's
either zero or two we didn't get any
concentration out of adding them
together but what if I take Z to be 1
minus X it's another zero one valued
random variable and X plus said is very
concentrated it's always 1 so certain
kinds of lack of independence are ok
from a concentration perspective we
still get concentration and other kinds
are not ok and this kind of dependence
we call negative dependence so X being 1
makes said less likely to be 1 and vice
versa
okay so let's generalize that to more
than one coordinate so now C will be a
vector of zero one entries M coordinates
it's a random variable negative pairwise
correlation is when for every pair of
coordinates if we have that CI is 1 it
lowers the probability of CJ being 1
formally that's this thing okay we can
also have other kinds we we can have
negative correlation if not just
pairwise it's sometimes defined this way
if for all subsets s of M the
probability that all the coordinates in
s are one should be less than the
product of the probabilities of the
individual coordinates being one so if
this was independent things would be
equal okay so here they have some
negative correlation can we get a
Chernoff bound in a setting like this at
least if we have a little bit more than
this we can so if both C and C
complement we're just switch the bits
from 0 to 1 and 1 to 0 are negatively
correlated then we get Chernov like
concentration of the sum of the CI
okay so people go yeah la de maka and
the Pala have shown this to boshy and
branch and have shown something very
similar a lot earlier and that's that's
what they build on so we're going to
move to a particularly nice class of
negatively dependent distributions which
are called strongly variety
distributions they were coined by poor
say Brandon and Liggett in 2009 it's a
property of a see ya binary random
vector of its distribution it has many
nice properties negative pairwise
correlation negative association closed
under conditioning and marginalization
and of course the definition is that the
generating polynomial of this variable
is real estate okay but we're not gonna
worry very much about the polynomials in
in this talk we're just gonna use that
they do very good things for us
okay so examples of this are uniformly
sampling K items without replacement
getting random spanning trees
determinantal point processes volume
sampling symmetric exclusion processes
we're going to focus on a slightly
restricted class which is called K
homogeneous strongly arriving which is
when the number of ones in the vector is
always exactly K okay we can get a
Chernoff bound in the matrix setting for
these variables so this is what we show
so a strongly Riley matrix Chernoff
bound now we have a collection of fixed
a I D PI D matrices that are positive
semi definite we get a vector of zero
one entries here M coordinates that's K
homogeneous strongly writing then we
form X as the sum over these random zero
one entries as our coefficient times the
a is and then exactly is in the
independent case we define a spectral
norm of the expectation to be mu and
each of the AI should always be bounded
in spectral norm by r and
we get this probability bound and it's
important to mention that there was a
scalar version of this due to Perez and
Pimentel before this okay this what do
we need to plug in to get concentration
so if epsilon is 1/2 and R is 1 and mu
is log t by tau log K we get a
probability P out of town this is worse
than what we had in the independent case
by this factor log K and I think that's
an artifact of our proof and something
that it would be nice to get rid of okay
just to do one other parameter setting
we can take epsilon to be larger than
one if epsilon is a log K and R is 1 and
mu is 10 log T by tau we also get a
probability band of tau and in this
regime a bound is tight because I think
these that's right will have an almost
matching lower bound because here this
epsilon doesn't really it doesn't matter
that there is a log K here
once you have big epsilon so this is
this is correct and yes in the Peris
Pimentel thing there is something that
looks like maybe it should be K so
sometimes things go well for us in the
matrix setting I guess
okay so now we're gonna do an
application of this graph approximation
using random spanning trees so let's
define we we're going to think about an
a weighted undirected graph G with
vertices v edges E and edge weights W
that just assign a positive way to every
edge but all of my examples the original
graph will be unweighted this is just to
keep things simple everything applies
immediately to the weighted case we'll
say that there are n vertices and now
let's think about spanning trees of G
what are they
here's a graph G spanning trees are
collections of n minus 1 edges that
connect the graph so here are the
spanning trees of this graph here's
another slightly bigger graph here is
all its 8 spanning trees okay let's pick
a random tree by which I mean uniformly
amongst these if there are weights that
you have to define it correctly but
we're going to just think about the
original graph being unweighted so now
let's ask some things about this
distribution of random spanning trees so
does the sum of a few random spanning
trees resemble the graph it sounds like
a nice concentration type question okay
but how do we get started on that like
what does resemble mean so a starter
question could be is the weight across
each cut similar and an even more basic
question could be are the weights even
similar in expectation like if I'm
thinking about proving things by
concentration of measure my objects
should at least an expectation behave
like the thing that I'm saying it's
close to so I'm going to say I want to
generate trees that somehow an
expectation look like the original graph
and then see if they also with high
probability look like the original graph
so let's start with just getting the
weights right in expectation so we're
thinking about picking a random tree
let's say that the probability of a
certain edge being present is PE okay so
for example this edge the probability is
1/2 this edge the probability is 5/8 now
to get the expectation right I'm going
to reweighed the edges of the spanning
tree such that when they do appear in
the spanning tree they get blown up by a
factor 1 over PE times the original
weight and this happens right with
probability P that's the probability of
the edge being present and of course the
weight is zero if the edge is not over
there and now the expectation of the
weight of the edge in the tree is
exactly PE times 1 over PE times the
original weight which brings us back to
the original weight so I just have to
blow up the edge weights by a lot to get
the expectation right and clearly I
could do this regardless of what the
probabilities are here as long as
they're nonzero
okay so what does it look like here is a
graph with my original weights here is a
particular tree and then with the
re-weighted edges as they should be
here's another tree with related edges
and in general we are taking expectation
of a random trees we scaled the edges up
by 1 over PE and then this makes sure
that in expectation the graph edge
weights are the original graph
expectation over the random trees is
that statement clear so now we got the
average weight equals the original
weight so then we can ask things like
does the tree behave like the original
graph at least now let's write an
expectation okay so one way to make that
question precise is to say two cuts in
the tree behave like cuts in the
original graph so what's a cut right
it's a subset of the vertices and then
the weight of the cut is the weight of
the edges that cross from one side of
this subset of the vertices to the other
so the weight here of the cut s 2's
compliment is just the sum of the edge
weights of edges that have one endpoint
in s and the other endpoint as
compliment and then we'd like it to be
the case that for all cuts the weight
across the cut in the tree is
approximately equal to the weight in the
graph say with high probability but this
is and this would be our concentration
statement ok so this would be saying
that the graph the random tree behaves
roughly like the graph a with high
probability but this is too much to ask
of of one tree how many let's get a
feeling for how many edges are necessary
so we could think about a simpler
sampling process so independent edge
samples so here we have a graph G now
we're going to sample the graph by
flipping a coin for each edge to the
side of the edge should be present okay
this gives us a random graphs here is a
random graph with independent edges all
the possible outcomes ok so this can be
completely empty it can have all the
edges we're just flipping a coin
independently for each edge now so I
might get this random graph I might
this one and of course we can get the
expectations right in any sampling
process like this again by just re
weighting the edges okay so now I have
my random graph H to get the expectation
right the weight of the edge should just
be one over the probability that the
edge is present times the original
weight because that happens with
probability P E and otherwise we put it
to zero so the expectation of that edge
is now the expectation of the weight is
now the original weight okay so for this
independent sampling thanks to her and
cargas showed in ninety six that if you
sample edges independently with well
chosen coin probabilities you have to be
sensible about it PE and then you so you
pick the coin probabilities then you
flip coins independently for each of the
edges then h has on average epsilon
power minus two and such that epsilon so
so we pick these parameters epsilon and
then we sample enough edges that h has
on average epsilon power minus two n log
squared and edges then with high
probability for all cuts in the graph
the weight in the random graph of the
cut is within a plus minus EPSA 1 plus
minus epsilon factor of the original
weight so now we can get concentration
okay but we have n log squared and edges
to get this whereas the spanning tree
just has n minus 1 edges what's the
proof sketch so you count the number of
cuts of each size in the graph and then
you do concentration bounds chef bounds
for each of the cuts and it's important
that there can't be too many small cuts
in the graph so you can your turn off
bounds don't need to work with as high
Pro what should I say there are a few
small cuts in the graph there are many
large cuts but that's okay because the
large cuts are more concentrated
okay now back to our spanning trees so
if it's too much to ask for one tree to
behave like the original graph maybe we
can ask for the sum of a couple of trees
to hit behave like the original graph so
let's try to average two trees together
so you have one random tree and another
one I average the two of them together I
get this graph and I can ask is that
close in expectation and with high
probability to the original grass so we
already have yet the expectation is
right so
Fumi and Harvey and hariharan and panic
rahi showed independently in 2010 that's
something like this works so let H be
the sum sorry the average of T of these
rebated random spanning trees where T is
epsilon power minus 2 log squared n then
with high probability for all cuts in
the graph the weight in this sum of very
small number of random spanning trees is
close to the weight in the original
graph so now we get our concentrations
do
okay and the proof sketch this is like
very simple there there are other parts
to these papers I should say it's just
banks who are cut counting and get again
and then the fact that scalar Chernov
works for negatively correlated random
variables so the only concentration
bounds that you are proving were just
you're just doing scalar turn off and it
just works immediately for negatively
correlated random variables and it turns
out the edges are negatively correlated
in a random spanning so here there's
really no work that you have to do
technically okay and notice that the
edge count
so each spanning tree has about n edges
so the total edge count here is let's
forget about epsilon is n log squared n
which is exactly the same as thanks who
are in Carter cut okay but you can get
it seems like this is something to do
because you would want the distribution
of spine trees what the toe be so edges
are the same as in pencil so here there
oh yes yeah sorry yeah that's a they
have kind of a like ice yeah they argue
the right way to handle that so there's
kind of a simple argument that the
effective resistances do close to what
you want that's a good point yeah okay
so Koya alb Rademacher and then Paula
showed an interesting result given an
unweighted bounded degree graph G you
let H be the sum or the average of just
order one unweighted random spanning
trees of G then with high probability
for all cuts you get a 1 over log and
lower bound in the weights here and a
the weights are upper bounded by the
weight in the original graph
this you can't hope to do with
independent random sampling because the
graph is likely to be disconnected when
you only sample enough edges like order
and edges so that's very interesting you
can make your trees to a little bit
better and the proof sketch is banks or
cargo cut counting where you use that
the first tree is likely to get small
cuts right and then you sort of say you
condition on now only cuts where the
where I was very off in the first tree
do I need to worry about for the later
trees and then you also use scaler
trough works for negatively correlated
random variables okay so now let's ask
about preserving more than cuts okay so
to do this we're going to associate
matrices and quadratic forms with our
graph and then we're going to ask
whether the random graphs approximately
preserve these matrices so the one of
the things we're going to talk about is
a will associate what we call a
laplacian matrix with the graph so a
laplacian is given in terms of weighted
undirected graph G with vertices V edges
E and edge weights W and the laplacian
is an N by n or a number of vertices by
number of vertices matrix that describes
G we build it this way on each edge we
put a spring between the vertices so
each edge of the graph now let's think
about getting a vector of positions
along the real line so and then nailing
down each vertex X a at position is
sorry each vertex a at position X of a
along the real line so this is going to
stretch out all of the springs of the
graph and then we could ask how much
energy is stored in these Springs by
stretching them out so the length of
each spring will be X a minus X B where
if this is an edge between an P and then
highschool physics says that the energy
of the spring will be the spring
constant times the length squared which
is equal to the weight if we take weight
to be the spring constant times this XA
minus xB squared and then the laplacian
is just the quadratic form in a the
Maitri
that make sure that if we form a
quadratic form like this X transpose LX
it measures exactly all the spring
energies okay so that's what the
laplacian does so it's just this
quadratic form and the laplacian is the
sum over edges wait at the edge times
this length of the edge squared this is
we can also think of as a sum of little
quadratic forms one for each edge which
just gives us the spring energy for that
one edge so then I can also think of the
laplacian is the sum of little baby
laplacian so one per edge in the graph
and now that baby laplacian just has to
give me the quadratic form for a single
spring and then I can build the
plasticine of the graph by adding all of
these together let's see how to do a
laplacian of a single edge so here's the
laplacian of an edge between vertex a
and vertex b it has a one on the
diagonal for vertex a one on the
diagonal for vertex B and a minus one on
the a B off diagonals and zero
everywhere else and then we scale the
whole thing by the weight of the edge
okay so let's build the laplacian of a
graph here's the graph on three vertices
let's put an edge weight one between
vertex one and vertex two it has a one
on the diagonal for vertex one I want on
the diagonal for vertex 2 and a minus
one on the one two off diagonals
put an H three way to between vertex one
and vertex three it has a two on the one
and three diagonals and a minus 2 on the
one three off diagonals edge of weight
one between vertex 2 and 3 gives us this
matrix adding all of them together gives
us the laplacian of the whole graph
so now we can ask questions about this
matrix is it preserved by random graphs
that we hope resemble our original
matrix or original graph so suppose that
H is a random weighted graph such that
for every edge the expected value of the
weighted edge and the random graph is
equal to the original weight of the edge
in the graph then the expectation of the
laplacian of the random graph is just
the laplacian of the original graph and
we can ask does the laplacian of the
random graph behave like the laplacian
of the original graph okay so one way to
ask that is to ask whether the quadratic
form is approximately preserved so we
ask whether for all vectors X which have
a number of per vertex is the quadratic
form in LG a close to the quadratic form
in ll H this is the random one so we'd
like it to be within a multiplicative
plus minus 1 a plus minus epsilon 1 plus
minus epsilon with high probability now
is that a useful quantity to preserve
well once sanity check is it implies
that cuts are preserved because if I
take X to be the indicator of one side
of a cut then the quadratic form in the
laplacian is just the weight across the
cut so if I preserve quadratic forms I
certainly also preserve cuts it turns
out there's an important distinction you
get more here and this more is crucial
for things like solving linear equations
so this is one of the reasons we care
about these a spectral approximations as
we call
now Spillman and Srivastava fuel down
there showed that you can preserve
quadratic forms by sampling edges
independently and use that to produce a
sparse approximation of your original
graph so if your sample and edges
independently with well chosen coin
probabilities PE such that H has on
average epsilon power minus 2 n log n
edges then with high probability for all
X the quadratic form is preserved up to
a factor 1 plus minus epsilon so what
are these well okay how do we prove this
so here I stated a version that you can
prove using a theorem of trop this
matrix Chernov originally I think Akhil
and then used a slightly different
theorem this one the trops theorem only
came later so what do you do you bound
the spectral norm of each of the
individual sample edges and then you
apply matrix Chernov concentration
that's it and then you have to do you
know calculate see what comes out one
thing that's nice here is you get
concentration at this level of edges
right so you're getting n log n edges
but it implies that cuts are preserved
but your sampling log in fact if fewer
than you did with banks or Karger so
you're doing a little bit better despite
getting something that's stronger than
banks or Carter so what are these well
chosen coin probabilities it turns out
you should you know you should scale the
probabilities overall so that they sum
to like you're your expected number of
edges is the right number but other than
that they should be proportional the
probability of n should be proportional
to the max over all vectors X of how
large can the quadratic form be in this
this single edge versus how large is it
overall so how much of the spring energy
can come from this one edge should
determine your probability of sampling
it so now let me ask a seemingly
completely unrelated question what is
the marginal probability of edges being
present in a random spanning tree right
this doesn't have anything to do with
with this independent sampling but it's
the same so it's also proportional to
these things okay
so it seems like there's a relationship
between Spillman Srivastava style sparsa
fication or a sampling of a graph and
sampling random spanning trees the
marginal probabilities are the same up
to an overall scaling okay so then it
seems reasonable to ask does this mean
that I should get concentration out of
sampling random spanning trees and
spectral concentration and we can prove
things like this with our matrix
Chernoff bound so if we let H be the
average of a number of random spanning
trees where T here is epsilon power
minus 2 log squared M then we get that
the laplacian of this sum of random
spanning trees is similar to the
original graph laplacian with respect to
quadratic forms up to a factor 1 plus
minus epsilon so that's nice
note though that this log squared should
probably just be a login it's not even
better than that as we'll see in a
moment but yeah the proof sketch so we
need to bounce some norms of sampled
edges this comes immediately from
Spillman Srivastava so like this this
the choices of sampling probabilities
that they made were very much geared
towards bounding norms and then we apply
our strongly Rylee matrix turnoff
concentration results and then it just
comes out immediately okay so if we have
this quadratic form and an average of
this number of spanning trees it's a
good approximation of the quadratic form
in the original graph we can show a
lower bound
foom in Harvey and it all they had a
like a similar but not quite this lower
bound so we just wanted to make it clear
exactly what's going on for the spectral
case here we get T a epsilon power minus
2 log in trees are needed for a spectral
specified so you could have hoped that
just sampling random spanning trees was
actually significantly better than
sampling edges independently because it
seems nice that the graph stays
connected but at least with the uniform
random spanning trees that's not the
case okay but it's an open question
what's the right number of logs I don't
think it's log squared I think it's log
n ok we can prove some more things so
for a single of these aree weighted
random spanning trees we can show that
the quadratic form and the single tree
is upper bounded by log n times the
quadratic form in the original graph for
all X with high probability this turns
out if you think back to a Nima's talk
that if you have a epsilon it's not
important if you weren't a Nima's talk
this is just a very smaller side if you
have epsilon spectrally connected graphs
your random tree is epsilon log n
spectrally thin okay so it's it's like
actually the conditions that you know
it's like the best tree except off by a
factor log n ok so Nima told us that the
best tree gets epsilon spectral Ethan
okay we have some lower bounds in some
graphs with probability exponentially
close to one there exists X such that
this fails to be bounded above by log n
over log log n times the quadratic form
and it fails to be bounded below by the
original quadratic form on some other
vectors so it's not that you can just
rescale your sample matrix okay you just
have to kind of it's of one side
inequalities you want to check that
there is something going on on the other
side to also by the way on a ring graph
there always exists x and y such that
the quadratic form in the tree is not
upper bounded by the quadratic form in
the graph and simultaneously even a very
small constant times the quadratic form
and the graph is not a lower bound to
the correct form in the tree oh yeah
that's a cycle sorry so now let's talk
about proving this strongly Riley matrix
Chernoff bound so we're going to focus
on an illustrative case just this log in
upper bound on a single tree for all X
with high probability it turns out this
has all of the ideas okay so after
you've seen this it's just a short
exercise to get the general proof we
need one thing called the loner order
which is a partial order on symmetric
matrices I think maybe most of you know
it it says that a is less than B if
these are symmetric matrices if for all
X x transpose ax is less than x
transpose BX okay so now I can rewrite
this goal statement that I had of saying
that the quadratic form in the tree was
upper bounded by log n times the
quadratic form and the graph for all X
is just saying that in the slogan or
order the laplacian of the tree is upper
bounded by log n times the laplacian of
the graph
so what's gonna be the proof strategy
this I doubt will make sense to most of
you I'm just gonna kind of lay it out
and then we'll fill it in and we'll see
what what what these words actually
means so let's just only spend a minute
on this we're going to convert the
problem into something called dupe
martingales then we'll be able to use a
tool called matrix martingale
concentration there will be some
unpleasant conditioning that happens
along the way of like saying that
certain edges are doing certain things
then we deal with that conditioning via
a coupling and then the coupling
immediately does everything for us
bounding norms of certain samples and
bounding variants and the whole thing
isn't too bad so much of this is just
really about staying calm in the face of
a lot of matrices floating around okay
so we're going to convert the problem
into something called a martingale so
what's a martingale it's a sequence of
random variables y 0 through YK such
that the expectation of Y I conditional
on the previous ones is just Y I minus
once so an expectation at every step
nothing is changing if I was being
formal I would have to say something
about filtrations but I'm not going to
do this here is five samples of a of a
martingale a scalar valued martingale so
these blue curves this is one martingale
that at any point is equally it's
expectation is zero or like in
expectation it stays constant going
forward but in reality it sort of will
zigzag around that place so all of these
blue lines should stay close hopefully
to this their original expectation and
many concentration bounds for
independent random variables can be
generalized to the martingale case to
show that the last variable in some
sequence is close to the first one with
high probability
so why do martingales exhibit
concentration so each difference between
by i and by i minus 1 0 mean conditional
on the previous outcome so this is this
expectation is 0 mean then if each of
these differences is small we can try to
break down the difference between the
last variable in the sequence YK and the
first one y0 as the sum of these y i
minus y minus 1 which are each zero mean
and we can hope that they cancel out
over time because they're also
conditionally zero means okay so that
was general martingales but our problem
didn't have any martin gills in it so
now we're going to use the strategy
called doop martin gills which is a way
to create martingales out of things that
don't have any martingales in them so
what's a doop martingale it's a strategy
for solving the following problem so
first let's just understand the problem
you have a collection of random
variables gamma 1 through gamma k you
want to prove concentration for the
function of a function of gamma 1
through gamma K where you hope you want
to say that f is stable under small
changes to gamma 1 through gamma K and
then it seems reasonable that maybe this
random variable should be close to its
expectation with high probability okay
now an absolutely essential point for us
will be that you can use doop
martingales even when your random
variables here are not independent okay
but then you also need that these random
variables are somewhat stable under
conditioning on what some of them are so
if these variables can do absolutely
crazy things when I conditioned on what
a few of them are I can't now any hope
to prove concentration using this
strategy anymore so we need stability of
both kind of the outcomes of the gammas
under conditioning and of the function
itself of the gammas so what's going to
be the doop martingale so you think
about picking a random outcome from your
actual distribution so your gamma 1
through gamma k but then you only reveal
slowly so why 0 will be the expectation
of just over the original distribution
of f of gamma 1 through gamma ki y 1
will be the expectation conditional on
gamma 1 the outcome that we actually got
for the first variable y 2 will be the
expectation conditioned on both y 1 and
y 2 all the way through YK is the
expectation conditional on all of the
variables but that's not an expectation
anymore right now I've revealed what all
of the outcomes were so I just get an
actual outcome from the distribution so
the dupe martingale is a way to reveal a
Marting an outcome through a sequence of
steps and okay
what's good about this well this forms a
martingale okay so the expectation of y
one is you know expectation over the
choice of gamma one of the expectation
conditional on gamma one so this gamma
ones they just undo each other you get
back the expectation with no
conditioning which is y zero okay so
this works at every step so why I minus
y I minus one conditional on previous
steps is zero mean so it's a martingale
and I didn't say anything about gamma 1
through gamma K being independent in
order for this to work
so now we'd like to show that YK is
close to y0 ie the random outcome that
we actually care about is close to the
expectation and tube martingale should
then help us do that right especially if
these steps which are zero mean are
somehow well-behaved
additionally so bad should have like be
small so what's gonna be our dip
martingale for revealing a random tree
so we're going to reveal one tree edge
at a time but what I mean here this is
very important I don't mean that we look
through each of the edges of the graph
and say whether there's an edge there or
not I mean that I write down the indices
of where are the edges of the tree and
then I've revealed these indices one at
a time so let gamma I to note the index
of the ice edge of the tree so for
example this is edge ten could be an
outcome so it's the tenth location in
the graph and so they all all the edges
have an index and then we reveal where
the edge is land so now we can define
the tree as gamma 1 through gamma n
minus 1 this these n minus 1 indices of
where the one's land now our function of
these indices will just be the laplacian
of the tree and then we started with y 0
is the expectation of the laplacian of
the tree notice that I sort of threw in
matrices suddenly right before we I
think I was thinking of a scalar random
variable this function now I made it a
matrix that's going to be fine
so y0 here is a matrix valued thing it's
a it's just the expectation of the
laplacian y1 is the expectation of the
laplacian conditional on where the first
edge lands and yn minus one is the
expectation of the laplacian of the tree
conditional on where all the edges land
which is just through the plasting of
the tree and it's a martingale the
expectation of Y I minus 1 I minus 1
conditional previous steps is 0 ok so
this was our tube martingale now we want
to show that yn minus 1 the last
variable in the sequence which is just
the laplacian of the tree is close to
the first variable which is the
expectation of the laplacian of the tree
yn minus 1 minus y 0 we then break it
down into a sequence of these individual
differences why I am minus y I minus 1
and then the question is can we show
matrix martingale concentration and
there is already a tool developed for
this matrix 3 minutes due to trop
there's actually a lot of different
matrix martingale concentration results
but this one tends to be much stronger
in my experience in a lot of contexts
than many of the other ones but I'm
stating a slightly restricted version
that just has sort of what we need okay
so this is not the fully general matrix
treatment so to prove what we want we
need that why I am minus y -1 has
spectral norm at most 1 and then we need
that the variance defined in the
following weird way it's is is at most
log m so what is this variance it's a
matrix and then we take a spectral norm
of that matrix it's the sum over I
expectation of Y I minus y I minus 1
squared conditional on previous steps
when we add up all of these matrices and
they somehow count as a variance
okay this part is difficult often when
you're dealing with matrix models
so this conditioning yeah oh it's
summing over the indices of the edges so
we have n minus 1 so edges going from 1
through n minus 1 so we're revealing the
locations of each of the N minus 1 edges
inside of the variance start somewhere
in the middle because no so it's at each
step a I get a variance for this step
which is a matrix valued object but when
I compute what that variance is I have
to compute an expectation conditional on
the previous steps the your you might be
uncomfortable because this is actually a
random object okay so this conditioning
means that exactly what the value of
this matrix is is a random object okay
so that's very weird and I'm asking for
that to always be bounded by log N and
I'm just saying that this is the
condition because we can actually prove
this you don't need to prove something
quite this strong to prove a
concentration so if you're not quite
able to prove that the variance which is
a random object is always small if it's
sometimes small with a small probability
is sometimes big you can still deal with
it but here we're going to
deterministically control this random
matrix does that help yes yeah yeah I
mean like this is what happened before
so you don't need any independence
because the edges are not independent
here right yeah yeah no I just need zero
mean yeah
and absolutely don't have anything like
independence
so this variance of the random quantity
no I mean like that would actually be
enough but we're just gonna prove that
it's always less than login in this
particular setting but with high
probability would be sufficient okay so
like this conditioning is difficult how
can we understand why 42 right like the
expectation sorry that this is being cut
off
it says the expectation of the laplacian
of the tree conditional on where the
first 42 edges of the graph land right
that's like a distribution that I have
no idea like about so now that to think
about that the thing about how does
conditioning change the distribution so
here we have a graph we want to
condition now on this edge being in the
spanning trees so here we have the
original eight random spanning trees of
the graph right there eight possible
outcomes here we have five possible
outcomes in the conditional distribution
so now I want to pick an edge
conditional on the red edge being
present so I could do that I might get
this one and then we could ask a
question of how similar are the
distributions right so I have now the
distribution before conditioning and
after and I want to argue somehow that
they're actually not too different and
this will then help us show that our
martingale is nice so one way that I
could try to argue that they're not too
different is that I could pick a random
outcome from each of the two
distributions and see if they look kind
of similar so yeah I picked a random
outcome from one and a random outcome
from the other random outcome from one
and from the other and now I could think
more carefully about this if I just want
to try to prove that these things are
not too different I could try to pair up
the two distributions such that I sample
one tree from this distribution so it
has to truly be from this distribution
then I sample one tree truly from this
distribution but I think of sampling the
pair together in such a way that I try
within you know the constraint that the
marginals have to be these two
distributions I try to make the trees as
similar as possible so that's a way to
try to prove that
two distributions aren't too different
and that's what's called a coupling so
there you can imagine that there could
be many couplings a bad coupling would
be that just this is sampled completely
independently from this one we want to
somehow pair up the trees well so for
example I might say that okay when I
sample this one and this one that's
perfect right there equal I sampled this
one and this one they're equal but what
happens when I sample a tree from the
original distribution that I can't get
in the conditional distribution then I
might pick some other tree and look at
the difference here's the kind of
symmetric difference in edges it's two
edges get this random tree from the
original distribution I get this tree
here what's the difference
it's four edges so that was worse I
might get this tree what's the
difference it's two it's this one
this tree difference is two edges this
one with this tree difference is two
edges so I had some flex build here
right I could pair it with this one or
with this and get a two edge difference
so what's the best I can do
it turns out that there is a coupling
you don't need to parse it really right
but there's a coupling such that I get
the uniform distribution of these and
the uniform distribution on these and
the edges are their most different in
two places okay and for this particular
example as far as I know it's unique I
think we recheck that so that's very
weird okay so here what what is this
it's called the stochastic covering
property it says that for k homogeneous
strongly rival distributions remember k
homogeneous this says we have like a
fixed number of edges in our tree a
coupling with difference at most two
always exists when you just condition on
where one edge lands in the tree ok so
let's just focus on trees but it's I I
should have just written you know trees
here but it's true more generally for K
homogeneous strongly right this was
essentially proved by Boris a Brandon
and Liggett but it was Perez and
Pimentel who kind of clarified that this
is an important quantity a or poverty
okay but a key point for us was to
realize that the coupling table has even
more structure than that statement okay
so to keep track of it we're going to
introduce some actors Alice Bob and
Charlie want to form a tree by each
selecting one edge gamma 1 gamma 2 and
gamma 3 such that you get a tree so
notice here right all of our outcomes
they have three edges so Alice Bob and
Charlie can build the tree together but
now Alice picks gamma one how does that
how much does that restrict the the
choices of Bob and Charlie right so here
we have the conditional distribution
given that Alice picked this green
dotted edge is gamma one so now we want
to use the coupling to prove in a sense
that this hasn't changed things too much
that it still looks reasonably similar
to this distribution and we do that by
saying that after Bob and Charlie have
chosen their edges so they have to
choose them so that we get a tree over
here they enlist another friend Anna to
pick an extra edge gamma tilde one
so it's like a different version of
Alice's edge and then it turns out that
Ana can choose that edge such that Ana
Bob and Charlie obtain the original
distribution while Alice Bob and Charlie
obtained the conditional distribution so
we recovered the original distribution
by adding a make up edge to the
conditional distribution so for example
this is what the coupling table is
saying here
ana picks this edge and we get this is
the outcome here in the coupling ana
picks this edge this is the coupling
table outcome so this tree is the Alice
Bob and Charlie
this tree is Ana Bob and Charlie okay
and so on so Alice Bob and Charlie are
doing the conditional distribution with
the same outcomes Bob Charlie and Ana
are doing the original distribution okay
this turns out to be extremely powerful
y1 minus y0 is the expectation of the
laplacian of the tree conditional on
gamma 1 minus the expectation of the
laplacian of the tree not conditional on
anything but I can think of that as the
expectation of what Alice Bob and
Charlie do conditional on what Alice
chose minus the expectation of what Ana
Bob and Charlie do
conditional on what Alice did this is
very weird because I rewrote the
original distribution expectation using
information about Alice and then I made
Ana make sure that we got back the
original distribution okay so now Bob
and Charlie cancel out and we're just
left with the difference between what
Alice did and the expectation of what
Anna did conditional on Alice's so I
went from what seemed like it could just
be a distribution of two arbitrary trees
to a very special difference with lots
of cancellations and I know that I can
bite it as one edge - an expectation of
edge yeah so the tree funds like the the
tree of an above and Charlie is
independent of what Alice does
completely it's not independent it's
very very dependent okay so in the
coupling table right
like what Alice what Anna has to do if
you get this tree is she has to pick
this thing with probability something
this thing with probability something in
this thing with probably something but
for the purposes of doing a difference
it doesn't matter okay so so it yeah
yeah it's probably in a second yeah I'm
not not sure if I'm getting the
terminology right okay okay yeah sorry I
should say I don't know I don't know
whether that's true yet okay I don't
know you're happy to learn more after
the talk then yeah okay so now let's go
back to symbols right because who is
stronger fact an antenna stochastic of
inappropriately yes if you give me any
edge there's a distribution on the other
edge yeah yeah and that's very important
because we're going to use this
characterization quite a lot but
presumably this holds for all that
songwriting yes yes yep and it's kind of
there's nothing like it's kind of
immediate from just thinking about the
earlier proofs so it's okay so now right
let's see what this said in in in matrix
land the laplacian of just the edge
gamma one right this is laplacian of
this baby laplacian of a single edge -
an expectation over what Anna does okay
so this can already help us prove that
the norm of a step change is always
small
okay so the spectral norm of the
difference between y 1 and y 0 is now at
most the spectral norm of this edge or
this expectation okay that's just like
when you have the spectral arm of the
difference of two PSD matrices it's most
the spectral norm of one of the two so
it's at most this thing or this thing
but this was the spectral norm of an
expectation I can get by convexity of
this norm that it's larger if I take the
expectation on the outside so now I just
have it's the max of the spectral norm
of what Alice does and the expectation
of the spectral norm of what Anna does
and then if I just say this turns out to
be a sensible kind of normalization but
the spectral norm of any edge is at most
1 now I have my bound so for experts I
should really be working in isotropic
position so the the I'm hiding something
about what the definition of these
spectral norms are there's like a slight
tweak that you need to do for these
statements to be exactly correct don't
worry about it it's very easy okay so
now let's remember that expectation of Y
1 minus y 0 is 0 now let's rewrite that
as this was the expectation of the
difference between what Alice does and
this expectation of what Anna does so if
that difference is zero I can rearrange
that to say that the expectation of the
laplacian that alice is generating is
equal to the expectation of the
laplacian that anna the makeup edge is
generating okay this is a very very
important symmetry that I've discovered
so like by looking at it this way right
so we had this extremely complicated
coupling table I was very scared
I'd like I made Zhou calculate what it
is and then we're like oh never mind you
don't need to understand it at all once
you know this at least forgetting to the
bound that we got you might need to
think more carefully about the coupling
table to lose the factor log
okay so now let's calculate variances
the expectation of Y 1 minus y 0 squared
well I can still can't oh my me also
just to emphasize this doesn't actually
have anything to do with laplacian
matrices okay
this is really an a statement about the
coupling table so like it's a statement
about probabilities of what Anna does
given what else does averaged over all
the different things that Alice can do
so it's really just it's like it's much
stronger than being a statement about
the laplacian so if you're not thinking
about the Plassey ins this would still
help you okay so the expectation of Y 1
minus y 0 squared we can now write it as
the expectation of what does Alice do -
what does Anna do averaged then we can
just break that up this is just doing
algebra then we can bound these squares
where the edges these each of these
terms we know have norm at most one so
we can bound the square the matrix by
just the matrix itself this works for
PSD matrices and then we can use that
these two expectations of what else and
what anitha's are the same so we get
just 2 times the expectation of what
Alice does
okay so yeah right now the next point is
that Alice is just an arbitrary edge of
the spanning tree so the expectation of
what she does is just one over n minus 1
times the expectation of what all the
edges do together which in turn is the
laplacian of the graph because the tree
was correct in expectation so the
expectation of this is just 1 over n
minus 1 times the laplacian of the graph
this is where in the matrix setting
we're getting something that's vastly
stronger than in the scalar setting it
turns out ok so now we have this upper
bound on the variance in a single step
okay anyway Alice and Anna did it for us
now what about later steps what happens
when I want to bound YT minus YT minus 1
by similar arguments it boils down to
bounding the expectation of the
laplacian of this single later edge
conditional on everything that happened
before and here you ought to do
something clever but we're not going to
we're just going to do a simple thing a
here's the graph we think about the
difference between the original
distribution and conditional on one edge
here is a nice fact we're picking a
random edge a random tree sorry down
here from the conditional distribution
it has this thing that we call shrinking
marginals which we wrote as a lemma but
it's really in Purcell Brandon and
Liggett already all edges except for the
one that I conditioned on are less
likely to happen in the conditional
distribution so let's say I look at this
edge now called black in the original
tree it has probability 5 over 8 or
0.625 of occurring in the conditional
distribution it has probability 3 over 5
or 0.6 of a current so all edges become
less likely when you condition on some
edge being present this is really why
we're working with this doop martingale
structure that we are
yes they stated in the right way like it
did I'm just it's nothing it's it's just
that okay so now we have these shrinking
marginals that says that the expectation
over what all of the remaining edges do
like what do all of the remaining edges
generate well it's something that in
terms of its incidence on each of these
edges of the original graph it's less
than what all the edges in the original
matrix all all the old edges not just
the remaining I just did all together so
all of the remaining edges that any step
have less sort of mass then the original
edges altogether so it's less what do
the remaining I just do then the
original tree now we asked him the
eighth step okay so what does one edge
do well there M - I edges remaining so I
just divide through by n minus I okay
and then I plug that in so now I have
like the behavior of a single edge in
every step bounded by something now I
can sum these variances and I get log n
times the laplacian of the graph and
let's not try too hard to parse this
because we're running out of time but we
started without do morning Gail which
had this you know end point which was
the laplacian of the grass the starting
point was the expectation of the
laplacian of the tree sorry I should say
laplacian tree here we broke it down
into steps the steps had small norm the
variance was controlled and it gets us
this log n no this should be there this
is one we're dealing with one tree but
when you're trying to get a sparsa fire
out of adding together many trees the
rate at which we need them were log
squared and sparser fires to get a
constant approximation and that should
just be log in okay so we proved our
strongly riling matrix Chernoff bound
let's have some open questions
so our bound for k homogeneous strongly
Riley has this log K in here I think
that shouldn't be there
so you should figure out the right way
to remove the homogeneity condition
maybe this is easier once you've dealt
with this but actually I think this is
probably very easy you should find more
applications right so I just looked at
one strongly Riley distribution this was
the random spanning trees but we had
sort of a list of other ones and it
would also be nice this will require
slightly different techniques to show a
log and sparsa fire from a constant
number of spanning trees so this was in
this is in the spectral case in the cut
case this was what boy album Paula and
Rademacher did questions so it comes
from the fact that I'm kind of doing as
like a pretty trivial thing to say what
do what does the later part of the
distribution conditional and stuff look
like I'm just saying that like say the
second half of all the edges the
expectation averaged over what all of
them does is less than what the whole
tree does but now when I look at what
one edge does amongst amongst the second
half it's sort of from that argument it
looks like it might sort of be twice as
important as any of the later things
sorry any of the earlier edges like the
first edge is like one over and the edge
that halfway is two over in one spank
tree it's tight yeah but I should note
that to get concentration for one
spanning tree like it's not that that
would like you wouldn't get something
too strong if this lock wasn't there
it says for this matrix matrix turn off
pound is there you sort of have to to
stable polynomials one from the strongly
Rolly measure and then one sort of from
the matrices a I oh I know we never
think about the matrices AI in terms of
their strong a variety Paul know you
could associate a polynomial where
they'd like and think about the spent
but we're not doing that they're stable
polynomials sounds reasonable to me
yeah I mean yeah yeah
I haven't actually thought about that
very much or at all yeah so can you just
follow up on something earlier I see say
what you mean by when you were comparing
this concentration gun with the amount
of perish it's like put like the
dimensions Wendy's one yeah yeah yeah so
I mean so the in the Perez Pimentel
thing what like what you're doing looks
something like epsilon mu squared by K a
okay and we have a log K
but wait but no actually sorry sorry
that that was me saying something wrong
because this mu here for them is like
the mule of a single variable so I think
actually the right statement is that in
the scalar case if you think about it
right it the K lock the K is not there
the lock case not there I think sorry I
was saying that wrong yeah and and I
guess then the removing commotion ages
what would you expect the bound to be
then you just have to expect it some
size of this set oh here so no no I mean
so notice that like if there was no
dependence on K here it doesn't matter
what K is like so now I don't need any
homogeneity yeah yeah no no I agree no
no I but but I mean it's like he was
asking what should the parameter be in
the non-homogeneous version so you could
ask first like what if so what if I want
to do this first which might actually be
fine yeah then you would probably get
like log D here if you want to like kind
of in a trivial manner or like log
number of entries of your binary vector
sorry that's the right version do that
help so right so we had like our binary
vector had like size number of edges in
the graph and if you just kind of wanted
to only deal with the remove homogeneity
condition then we just have a log number
of edges here okay so that that follows
from your above no it doesn't follow
right now but like something like that
should be very easy to show
doesn't do a stick covering breakdown if
you know Jamie know there's some version
of it that's still true yeah yeah
yeah so you said there are graphs where
if you pick fewer than one word epsilon
squared Logan's funny please you don't
get ya is it true for the click I I
think like to get like the probability
level that we want we're just putting a
bunch of clicks that are really
independent but share one vertex so it's
like it's the behavior of the clique but
just like to get the high probability
like you can take many clicks okay then
it is just a clique then it's a I'm like
I'm there's like a difference between
whether you want for one tree and
whether you want high probability or
like it so for one of the bounds for the
epsilon thing I think maybe we need a
collection of cliques but it's never
it's never anything other than a clique
or collection of cliques yeah I don't
remember yes
okay thank you
[Music]
[Applause]